please German I've been asked to deliver
an important announcement from the
organizers of this year's comic-con
apparently there's a group of people
who've been attempting this is sad to
sneak into comic-con even though they've
been told repeatedly they've absolutely
no business being here I'm speaking of
course about the cast of Mamma Mia too
if they approach you do not I repeat do
not let them borrow your bags do not
open a door for them do not in any way
and get
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay look look look look
you guys are not supposed to be here not
that's crazy comic-con is the perfect
place for pop culture junkies to get a
fix of their favorite obsession Mamma
Mia - no that's the front rows just
being nice I'm sure nobody at comic-con
wants a fix of Mamma Mia - they just
don't come on Mamma Mia - has everything
for comic-con fans it's an epic sci-fi
fantasy set in the Mamma Mia verse
that's right I'm princess star Dazzler
defending Planet ABBA
and I'm the bad guy Baron von Batman and
these are our laser dancers Hey okay
look
I see what you're trying to do but admit
it Mamma Mia too is the antithesis of
comic-con it just is we have these
lights tappers that's not what they're
called and people come to comic-con for
cool merch and exclusive props from
their favorite movies they do cool merch
like this jar of official ABBA dancing
cream merit on your pants and dance and
exclusive props like this pair of male
Spanx actually worn by Pierce Brosnan no
it's more sci-fi and fantasy that's what
they want here well mama to has Meryl
Streep and Cher on screen together I'd
call that the ultimate fantasy it's got
all three ABBA songs we didn't use in
the first Mamma Mia movie including
their version of the Canadian national
anthem
[Music]
I appreciate I appreciate all the effort
but there's just no place at Comic Con
for Mamma Mia - there just isn't fine
but one quick question would it be okay
if we stuck around to see the cast of
Aquaman we're huge Jason Momoa fans you
can stick around but please get off my
stage okay sweet guys let's get out of
here
Mamma Mia style
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you